The Joe Rogan experience. But my,
my interested my interest is more in the sort of intersections of
religion and culture where people might not recognize they're being religious,
even though I would try to make the argument that they are well. I mean, I've,
I've, uh,
I've written a book called sacred matters that looks at these different, um,
kind of arenas where we're religious life, um, can be found in,
in cultural forms of activity. So, um,
like celebrity worship,
I would call a religious culture that has
systems of meaning different kinds of rituals, um,
possibilities for, um, discovering your true self,
a whole kind of value system that can be tied up. Yeah, that's interesting.
Celebrity.
Worship as a form of religion,
I've always thought of it as just hijacking the human reward system because, uh,
if we lived in a tribe of people, a small tribe, and there was one,
uh, great leader, you know, the battle scarred leader,
who's seen it all and can give us the information.
And he was the one talking we would listen, that would be, uh,
a person of great importance. And we all gather around and listen.
But when you see Brad Pitt in a movie screen and his face is 30 feet high,
and this music playing when he talks and a team of writers have carefully
constructed all of his words and this perfect sentence. And, you know,
it's just like, it's so moving and inspiring. And then we see them in real life.
Oh my God, it's really you. But meanwhile,
he hasn't really done anything other than pretend. Right. You know what I mean?
He's been pretending, I mean a great entertainer,
but he'd given us some wonderful distractions,
but it's not that he's led us through battle. Right. It's not that he's,
he's figured out how to find the food in the water. You know,
this is not what it is, but in our, our hijacked human reward system,
we treat him as though he is the great leader or even.
Someone like Oprah. I mean, he was more clearly, you know, in that sort of, um,
strange, uh,
middle ground between celebrity and spiritual leader of some kind.
So, you know,
obviously it's going to vary depending on what celebrity or you're talking
about, but, you know, just in terms of projections, our imagination,
where we invest, um, you know, our energies, you know, celebrities big,
but again, um, I'd like to talk about, uh, other things, uh, you know, as well,
um, that whether we're talking about politics or, um,
consumer culture or things, um, around medicine,
that there are religious qualities that don't have to do with the Bible
or with Mohammad or something.
Right. There's religious qualities in that, uh,
there's these very rigid ideologies that are treated like religions
that you have to follow. And there's also, um,
signs that people will hold up that they're complying in there,
along with this ideology. I'm one of them that I talk about a lot,
is people taking photos with masks on, on Twitter for their,
their profile picture, right? Like I know what you're doing. Right, right.
We all know what you're doing. Well, I mean, you know.
And messaging and thinking about, you know, bizarre use, you know? Yeah. It's.
It's bizarre when you see these patterns sort of repeated over and over again.
Right. Social media too, do the future of, of religion and, uh,
in terms of how it, um,
transforms and moves forward is an important kind of site
for religious activity and investments. And, um, you know,
where we're really gonna see the action what's happening on Instagram,
Twitter. Yeah. So.
When you say like religion that these things fall into
sort of religious behaviors or religious ideas, um,
you're not meaning like as handed down from a higher
power you're meaning as in people fall in with
the same sort of compliant behavior and patterns. And.
Uh, not necessarily. I mean, I, it's not,
it's not all just sort of compliance and, uh, it's one aspect, right.
Or conformity or something. It's, it's,
it's just meaning-making is how we try to live our lives in ways that, um,
can carry us on when we have to confront suffering and death and,
and as well as, um, you know,
issues around health and what are the sources that are available to people. And,
you know, as I've, I've said in my class many times,
I think popular culture is much more of an important kind of teacher
about religious ideas and values than, you know, the local priest.
How so? Because people pay more attention to it.
Absolutely. And because they're more swayed by it, you know,
because it has more of an impact and resonance, but.
It's so, it's,
so it's a dangerous way to sway things coming from someone who's involved in
distributing popular culture,
because there's so little thought put into the actual impact
of, of what it is and so much thought putting into it. Just what pops.
Yeah. Like what gets people to pay attention, right.
And money talks and money is sacred. You know what,
what's a more sacred in our society than making some money.
And that's a dry, you know, again, so there too,
we can talk about other religious qualities to capitalism. Well, you know,
there've been a number of, uh, scholars who've written on that topic and,
and made those connections. So, um, again, you know,
the action isn't taking place in the church it's taken place in, you know, uh,
music festivals, burning, man, you know, it's,
this is where again, I'm not making it.
I'm not trying to kind of over-generalize, but I think very much for, um,
especially younger people. Um, but baby boomers as well, you know,
where, where, you know, where does, where do I get my spiritual juices.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere, but after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking. Just go download Spotify much. Buh-bye.